[A young girl sitting at table handles a bracelet made of beads, putting it in her mouth, then back down on the table.
[She moves her fingers about her mouth, picking up and dropping the bracelet.]
[The beads are now placed in front of her, but covered with a white cloth. She loses interest and does not attempt to remove the cloth.]
[A young boy handles the bracelet while looking into the camera; then it is taken away and returned hidden under a white cloth.]
[He ignores the cloth, looking and gesturing to his right, and then appears uncertain.]
[Another boy is given a bracelet of beads and handles it, occasionally smiling.]
[Again the object is taken and returned to him under a cloth. He appears uncertain, then looks up and smiles.]
[Another child is presented with the beaded bracelet. The child slaps first the palm and then the back of one hand with it.]
[The bracelet is presented under a white cloth, and the child bends their head down, then looks around. The cloth is not touched.]
[The next boy picks up the bracelet and hands it back to a person offscreen.]
[After it's presented under the white cloth, he picks up the bracelet and cloth together and hands them to someone offscreen.]
[Different objects are placed in front of the children, one child at a time. They handle them and sometimes appear to smell or taste them.]
[The white cloth appears off and on. Some children play and show curiousity, others mostly ignore the objects and cloth.]
[A small object is placed under a larger one, then removed. Childrens' reactions vary. Some look for the missing small object.]
[The children continue to handle the objects, which come and go. There are multiple pieces which fit one into another.]
[Now the object is placed in front of the children but behind a clear barrier. The children respond in different ways, some with frustration,
some with an understanding that they must reach behind the barrier to retrieve the object.]
[Objects with candies hidden beneath them are placed in front of the children. The children find and eat the candies.]
[A mirror is placed in front of each child. Some seem to recognize themselves while others do not.]
[One girl mouths the mirror, as she has earlier items.]
[Others make faces at themselves or place their faces very close to the mirror. One boy points at his reflection.]